So we have the allusion of shared
memory, which is implemented by physical memories that
is strewn all over the entire cluster, and
the hope is that the application that is
running on the different nodes of this
cluster will actually get speed up with increasing
number of processors, but such speed up is
not automatic. If the sharing that we're doing,
even though DSM gives you the ability to
share memory across the network, recall what our
good friend Chuck Thacker told us. Shared memory
scales really well when you don't share memory.
So, if the sharing is too fine-grained, then
no hope of speed up, especially with DSM
systems. Because it is only an illusion of
shared memory via software, not even physical shared memory.
Even physical shared memory can lead to overheads.
So, this illusion through software can result in
even more overhead so you've gotta be very careful on how you share and what you
share. So the basic principle is that, the
computation to communication ratio has to be very
high if you want any hope of speed up. So in other words, the critical sections
that are execute to modify data structures
better be really, really hefty critical structures before
somebody else needs to access the same portion
of the data. So what does this mean
for shared memory codes? Well basically, if the code has a lot of dynamic data
structures that are manipulated with pointers, then it
can lead to a lot of implicit communication
across the local area network. You think you're
executing code accessing a pointer, but the pointer
happens to be pointing to memory that's in
a remote processor. So that implicit access to
a data structure pointed to by a pointer
in your program, can result in a network
communication across the network. Fetching something from here,
into your local memory. This is the bane
of distributed shared memory. That pointer
codes may result in increasing overhead
for coherence maintenance, for distributed shared
memory in a local area network. So
you have to be very careful on how you structure codes that can execute
efficiently in a cluster using DSM as the vehicle for programming.